JOSH LIVNI: Just hang tight and
we'll make sure everyone
has a chance to join before we
jump into the Styled Maps.
You're welcome to say
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], if you have
a question.
I think we by default
have people on
mute who just joined.
So we'll see if we can get you
unmuted, in case you have an
immediate question while we're
waiting for some more folks.
MALE SPEAKER: I do,
about Hangouts.
So not about Maps.
I'll save the Maps questions for
when there's more people.
But Mano included a link to
the Google Moderator--
excuse me, Google Moderator.
And there were different events
in Google Moderator.
So different previous instances
of the Office Hours.
But the link he sent
was empty.
So it went by default
when you went there.
I believe it was empty, or
maybe I didn't wait long
enough for it to refresh.
So I guess for someone who
hasn't used it much, what is
the protocol for adding
new questions.
What is the right spot
to add new questions?
JOSH LIVNI: Well, probably the
right spot is to tell us that
we made a small mistake and it
should have taken you directly
to this week's moderator,
rather than the default
moderator from our
previous one.
So, sorry for the
confusion there.
Next week we'll make sure that
the link is right and it goes
to the appropriate moderator.
But for future reference, if you
do come across something
like that, generally the
most recently created
one is at the top.
So if you then selected
the top left one--
and it should have a description
like, moderator
questions or just hangouts.
So there's a list of five or
six previous ones might be
noted on the left.
So just pick the top one and
add your question there.
But yes, next week we'll double
check and make sure it
goes to the correct week instead
of just the default
list of all of them.
And you're welcome to ask any
Maps questions as well.
We don't want to make you
repeat them later.
MALE SPEAKER:Oh, sure.
I had a couple that I put in
Moderator, which may or may
not be in the right place.
And sorry for my head appearing
large suddenly.
I was turning off a small
heater that I was using.
So my questions were
the ones about--
they were related
to map controls.
So I didn't know that today's
topic was styled maps, which
really interest me.
So I'm looking forward
to that.
But I've seen the MBC how to.
So using the circle and using
MVC controls, using the API.
And I've seen the couple of
examples in the example
section of the developer
documents, which is a home
control and a state saving
home control.
But I've been looking
for styleguides.
Specifically, I wanted to
create a control, for
instance, that is like a full
screen control for hours that
looks like the control that
is Maps/satellite.
And I can tell from looking at
the CSS that it's browser
dependent and resolution
dependent.
And essentially I was
asking, is there a
way to recreate that?
I mean, I could have CSS that
has those thousands of rules
and sort of do, if i.e., if
Chrome, if Safari, if this
other thing.
But really I wanted to
know what is the
right way to do that?
JOSH LIVNI: Yes.
There's two general approaches
here, I think.
One is to file a feature request
that we should publish
our CSS, or some way of doing
this in the API, where you can
not have to worry about copy
and pasting the CSS.
But there's also a way you can
create, for example, I think
it's really a control.
I'll have to check the reference
in a second.
A button that shows up next
to your other map layers.
And you can customize that
to do whatever you want.
So as long as you're happy with
it being part of, for
example, layer control, it will
look like your map and
satellite buttons, but it can
do whatever it is that you
might want, that's
not necessarily
just switching a layer.
An example of this is the
Google Earth API utility
library, which is part
of our Maps v3 third
party utility libraries.
And there's a button there
that says Earth.
We just added a button next
to the other ones.
But you click it and it calls
a bunch of custom code that
has an end result of putting
dibs on top of the map, and
showing plug-in and so on and
so forth, even though it's
technically part of
the layer control.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, yes,
I've seen those.
The examples--
JOSH LIVNI: So that would be one
way to sort of get it so
no matter what happens, even
if we change the style of
those buttons in future versions
or whatever, your
button will match.
But it doesn't give you the
ability to put it in some
other control elsewhere.
Although again, you can put
those controls off in a
separate dib and so forth.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
Yeah, I've seen that.
And I work at a university, so
I've seen examples of other
universities doing complete
custom controls.
They built the entire thing
themselves, usually for their
own layer controls and for
their own searches and
branding and so forth.
JOSH LIVNI: So if you didn't
want it to match
ours exactly, that's--
I mean, it's a little
bit of a hack.
But you might want to look at
that example of the API
utility library, and then you
could have that control do
whatever it is that you
want it to have it do.
MALE SPEAKER: I like that.
I would never have thought of
inserting into that array,
sort of having the box of little
bits of layer control.
JOSH LIVNI: On the proximity of
your control to the layer.
MALE SPEAKER:Right.
That actually helps a lot.
I'll have to play with that.
Thank you.
JOSH LIVNI: One for one.
I like that.
Excellent.
Yes, thank you.
I struggled with the same
question myself when I was
building that library.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh,
you created it.
That's you.
You're the author of that.
JOSH LIVNI: I am the
author of that one.
And I had a similar question
which is I had access to all
of the CSS and so forth,
but it didn't
seem appropriate to--
even if we did publish the CSS,
because we're going to
change that in future versions,
and then it would be
outdated and so forth.
MALE SPEAKER: So what does
it look like for you?
I mean, I can't--
it's even in line.
So I'm imagining that
you're not--
those things aren't inline
styles when you are on sort of
the Google side of the world.
Do you all use something--
JOSH LIVNI: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
library, and pretty much all
the tools that our team of maps
and developer relaions
put out, use the public APIs,
the exact same endpoint APIs
that you have.
All I meant is that I do happen
to have also access to
the code, that if I also felt
so inclined, I could have
filed a similar feature request.
And this is actually
a great way that we are able
to make things as developer
friendly as we can is, as we
build these tools we struggle
with the same things you guys
have struggled with.
And then when we chat to you
in Hangouts, we hear the
feedback you have, and then we
can go to our engineers and
say, hey, this is a problem that
we should try to solve.
And so, if it turned out in
this case that using that
layer control really was not
appropriate for you, that
would be great feedback.
And we could go task the Maps
team and say, hey, maybe
there's a way we could have some
generic control that you
could move around that had
similar styling, or something.
But as it turned out, it worked
well for that library,
and it sounds like it
might work for you.
MALE SPEAKER: It will.
It's not layer, technically,
but a full speed control is
sort of, kind of
in that world.
And isn't far from
map satellite
and a screen control.
I could sort of see those
being related
without being too crazy.
JOSH LIVNI: As long as it's
intuitive to the end user, and
that seems appropriate to me.
All right.
So I assume you had no trouble
joining this Hangout.
MALE SPEAKER: No.
I did last week's with Mano.
JOSH LIVNI: So you
were prepared.
MALE SPEAKER: So it took me a
while to get on, because he
had to see the comment and then
add me to the circle, and
then let me join.
So it was a little
bit challenging.
I'd done other ones.
I've done other--
I guess it was not Maps
API Office Hours.
It was a Google Map Office
Hour, previously--
JOSH LIVNI: [MULTIPLE SPEAKERS]
so that we have the ability to
live stream them on YouTube,
so anyone could watch, but not
necessarily participate in the
Hangout itself.
MALE SPEAKER:Which
is a great thing.
JOSH LIVNI: [MULTIPLE SPEAKERS]
so we have to grant explicit
permissions.
And so that's why we have
this new extra step.
Any other questions
while you have us?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, let's see.
Party--
office hours, indeed.
I guess, to go back to that, I
was going to ask if there was
a style guide, in general,
for controls and things.
Obviously, I can see what
is part of the API.
But I was wondering if there
were guidelines for what is
recommended for custom
controls.
JOSH LIVNI:No.
We really leave it up to you,
because we like to see
developers come up with some
creative ways of-- when people
are able to make whatever they
want, then maybe they'll think
of something we never did.
We don't want to say, here's
the way to make controls.
But we do put out examples.
And so there's the Maps v3
examples page you mentioned.
There's also--
I think there's a controls page
in the documentation,
which gives some additional
examples.
And the style of those examples
is just what we
consider a reasonable way to
program against the API.
But certainly, if you want to
build something that looks
outlandish or does something
really strange with different
JavaScript libraries, then you
should take full advantage of
the API to do that.
MALE SPEAKER:Yeah.
I noticed that the examples to
make it easier, and obviously
really portable, it uses
JavaScript to construct the
[? dittos ?] and the other
elements and the styles, and
it assigns those using
JavaScript inline.
And I actually found a
technique-- since my Maps page
is already using jQuery, you can
just do dollar jQuery and
put HTML in there and it
automatically creates that.
And then do a get zero and you
don't have to worry about it.
And also, it wasn't clear
that you could do CSS.
It was my own mental failing
of not realizing that
ultimately this is
part of the dom.
And standard CSS, if
you have IDs or
classes, will be applied.
You don't have to specify
everything in the JavaScript
like you do in your examples.
Which, I understand why you do
in the examples, but I sort of
thought it was you could
only do it that way.
JOSH LIVNI: I see your point.
And we could probably add
a comment in some of our
examples that makes it clear the
reason that we're inlining
the HTML and CSS is because we
want a single example there,
and not because that's
necessarily the recommended
approach for JavaScript
developers to
create new dom elements.
There's always good running
debate on that, you can find
anywhere, as to where the cutoff
is between too much
HTML and CSS, and just a tiny
little jQuery dib that you
want to insert in something.
So I think that's really up to
each developer, and a little
bit separate from our API.
But yes, we could make comments
in there that make it
clear why we're doing
it that way.
So I think, even though we're
not sure how many people are
potentially watching on YouTube,
we switch over to
introducing the Style
Maps stuff.
And that's what we'll do now.
So I think you can see a
shared screen up there.
Can you tell me if you see a
shared screen on our showcase?
MALE SPEAKER: I do.
I'm using a MacBook Air, and I
see the large window is you.
And I see my head, and then
I see the screen.
And if I click that, it's
just the screen.
JOSH LIVNI: I got the
same thing, so I
think we're all set.
So I'm going to go ahead and
start talking about this
developer showcase here,
which is fairly new.
I'm not sure if any of you guys
have noticed that we put
up new layout in our
developers.google.com for a
showcase for Maps, and of all of
our Maps documentation and
some other documentation is
also out there at the
developer site, Google.com.
So, pretty nice resource.
And notice that the URL here is
developers.google.com/maps.
And one of the most obvious
things you can do here is hit
the big, red view
showcase button.
And there's lots of great
examples in here to kind of
pull ideas from.
Some of the different creative
ways people are using Maps.
And you can take a look,
obviously open up the
JavaScript behind these pages,
get an idea of what people are
doing in this space.
And today I wanted to talk about
Styled Maps, because
it's one of my favorite
features.
And so what I'm going to do is
bring open this filter here.
I can choose to look at only
a subset of these maps.
And I'm going to choose the ones
that take advantage of
our Style Maps.
There's quite a few.
I'll just bring up a couple
to prove the point of
what Styled Map is.
Basically what it is, is this
idea that you can customize
the look and feel
of the base map.
When you go to maps like
google.com, we have a whole
bunch of stuff on the base map
that's really designed for
visitors of maps.google.com.
A whole lot of people looking
for driving directions,
looking for places.
That might not be the same story
that you're trying to
tell with your map.
And so, what we have here is
a bunch of different people
using Styled Maps to
tell their story
a little bit better.
I like this one, maps
without maps.
I'll bring that up.
So this one, it's kind
of hard to see what
you're looking at here.
But what they've done is remove
all the features except
for the labels.
I think it's kind of silly, but
it's a little bit clever.
And then--
KATHRYN HURLEY: No, I didn't do
it, but it's really cool.
JOSH LIVNI: I like the idea.
I probably wouldn't have
thought of this myself.
And then as we zoom in, we can
start seeing all of the
populated places and the
relative sparseness in some
areas of the country.
And anyway, the point here being
is we can remove a lot
of features and show just some
features to tell a really
different story than you
usually see with maps.
So maybe there's not a lot that
you could do with that
map, except prove the point of
how you can do really cool
styling and see the world
in a different way.
Let's take a look at another
great example,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
This is a really simple map, but
what I like about it is it
proves the point that if you
really want to tell a story
that has your data on top,
you're probably best off
getting rid of all of the
distracting elements that
might otherwise be on the map.
Again, with Giggle based map, we
want to show you where the
freeways are, where the local
transit stations are, and all
of these different things
probably not
relevant to this use case.
So I'll go down here.
There's tons of saturation
way down.
You get a nice gray scale map.
And now their markers
really pop.
They can style it, and it kind
of looks like our colors
aren't competing against their
grand colors in their website.
So just the simple idea of
toning down the saturation is
a great way of seeing how Styled
Maps can make it a
little bit less distracting to
overlay your data on top.
And we'll look at some
more examples later.
I see a couple more
people joined us.
So before I go into a couple
more examples, and then how
you might create your
own Styled Map--
I've got Davey here.
OK, great.
And yeah, if you have any
questions, Davey, you're
welcome to ask.
KATHRYN HURLEY:Just raise your
hand if you have a question.
JOSH LIVNI: --if you
have a question.
He's got a question.
He's always got good
questions.
How are you doing today?
I think you were muted there.
Are you still possibly muted
on your end, Davey?
DAVEY:I was still muted, yes.
JOSH LIVNI: Ok.
We're all set.
DAVEY: Doing great.
Just booked my flight and hotel
for Google IO, so--
JOSH LIVNI:Oh, you
got your tickets.
Congratulations.
It'll be great to
see you there.
Excellent.
DAVEY: I actually had
a question on
the street view API.
I don't know if that covers
the Google Maps family.
JOSH LIVNI: We'll try our
best to answer it.
You're welcome to
ask anything.
We'll just say we don't know,
if we don't know.
DAVEY:It's from an Android
perspective, basically.
Would it be possible to load up
a KML file or something, or
a collection of geo points and
stream it into kind of a
street view animation?
JOSH LIVNI: So there's
a few different
things going on there.
I'm not sure I fully understand
the question.
But I think what you're asking
is if you have a bunch of
locations in KML, perhaps a
line, perhaps a bunch of place
marked points, and you want to
be able to just display a
slide show kind of effect
with Street View.
Sure, you could do that.
So ignoring the Android part
of things, which I'm less
familiar with, as you probably
know from previous
conversations.
Certainly, the Maps API, you can
grab the location data out
of the KML, and then make a
separate call to the Street
View, using static image API or
the full-fledged API, and
have it move at whatever timing
it is that you see
appropriate.
There's no [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
read this KML that would
display it in Street View.
You'd have to parse It yourself
and do that, the
separate calls.
Does that answer
your question?
DAVEY: Yes.
I think I can pretty much figure
it out, how to do it
like web-based.
But I was wondering as there
is this native Street View
Android application, is it
possible to leverage the
capabilities of that native
Android app and--
JOSH LIVNI:That's a really
good question.
I think that the answer is no,
but I'm not 100% sure of that.
Not that you can't use that
Street View idea, but rather I
don't think there's a really a
direct tie to read it to KML
and then say, follow it
along kind of a thing.
So I'll have to ask
the Android team.
Or if you want, you can join
one of the Android Office
Hours and ask them.
But I'd be happy to pass on the
question to them, as well.
I don't know that offhand.
Sorry.
He looks like he's got another
question there.
I'm not sure if we muted him.
I can't hear him.
I think you're potentially
muted still.
MALE SPEAKER: He's got
another question.
DAVEY:I saw the demo that you
guys did in Austin with the
cap thing, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
demo.
Is there like any example
source code
available for that?
JOSH LIVNI:There is not
currently a great example.
But we're going to go
into a lot of detail
about how we did that.
Some cool things with web view
on Maps at the Aware
conference, which is
I think next week.
I should probably start
prepping for that.
And we're going to probably
have some things there and
afterwards that will
be pretty exciting.
DAVEY: That was a cool
demo, by the way.
JOSH LIVNI: There's a lof of
really amazing potential, I
think, with using the web dl.
So that's some pretty
exciting stuff.
So I'm not sure if they're
live streaming all of the
workshops at Aware.
I know they're doing
the talks, but
perhaps not the workshops.
So we'll definitely be
publishing some stuff online
in the days and weeks following
the conference.
DAVEY:Ok.
Cool.
Out of questions.
JOSH LIVNI: Out of questions.
All right.
Did you want to talk about
Styled Maps now, show any
example or demo's or
shall I hop to it?
KATHRYN HURLEY: Go ahead.
JOSH LIVNI: Me?
All right.
Freedom of the press?
That does look nice.
Have you heard of this one?
KATHRYN HURLEY: I might
have heard of it.
JOSH LIVNI: Why don't you
describe a little bit about
what we're looking at
here, this freedom
of the press website?
What do we have here, Kathryn?
KATHRYN HURLEY: Actually, I'm
not too sure of the details of
what this map is showing and
it being interrelated to
freedom of the press, somehow.
JOSH LIVNI: Oh, I thought
you knew all about it.
OK.
Well, let's take a look.
It is [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So what they've done
here is just
overlay the country polygons.
And one of the things you
often see when you have
semi-opaque polygons here is
that, again, an unstyled map
can detract from this overlay
story, because we're going to
have all of these different
colors and so forth pop out.
And so again, they've just
done-- oh, go ahead.
KATHRYN HURLEY: I think I know
one thing about these
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JOSH LIVNI: Oh yeah,
let's hear it.
KATHRYN HURLEY: I believe it
uses [UNINTELLIGIBLE] tools to
draw the polygons.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, and that's a
whole another usually tricky,
problem to solve aside from
styling the map is how to get
nice big data overlays
like this.
So that is a really
good point.
So if you have lots of
your own custom data,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is a great
thing to look at.
Let me take a quick
look and see--
is this the same as the
newspaper map, where they have
that kind of overlays?
KATHRYN HURLEY: It had a
lot of markers on it.
JOSH LIVNI:Had a
lot of markers.
So same thing.
And I think this is
also a Styled Map.
And again, going back to that
same general idea of Styled
Maps is, if you have a story to
tell, you're probably doing
well by really making sure that
only things that help
your story, in this case, labels
and where the countries
are-- get rid of the things that
detract from your story,
maybe lots of colors or other
things that would potentially
conflict with your overlays.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Especially
like this slide where the
markers really pop on it.
JOSH LIVNI: Exactly.
And if you do an overlay on
top of an unstyled map, it
would be a lot more difficult
to see the pattern and
different markers if you're
distracted by the background.
So let's go ahead and say if
we wanted to create our own
Styled Map.
I'm just going to give a really
brief introduction, in
my opinion, the easiest
way to do that.
The easiest way is
to do a search.
Your favorite way to search,
which for me is just typing up
top for Google Maps style
wizard, or something along
those lines and hitting an early
link which takes you to
the Styled Maps wizard.
KATHRYN HURLEY: And isn't there
a YouTube video as well?
JOSH LIVNI: Oh, yes.
We have a great screen cast
that also goes over that.
I'll see if we can get a link
up here, or tell you how to
find our screen casts.
But meanwhile, let's take a
look at the Styled Maps
wizard, which basically
starts you out with
our default map here.
Let's pick a location, say
Seattle, where I used to live.
Also known as the places API.
Although complete, we aren't
using Maps, and you're asking
people to type in locations
and think about taking
advantage of places they've
got on API auto complete.
And here we are, a basic map.
This is what our default map
looks like, and what the
majority of maps out
there look like.
But no need for your map
to look like this.
And so this is just a
kind of a wizard.
It let's you change, for
example, I mentioned earlier,
go to a gray scale view.
And already there's a lot less
distractions on the map.
Or you could turn
it up a notch.
And also go feature
by feature.
So if I just want the water,
for example, to have a
different hue over here and
maybe be a little bit darker,
then I can do that.
And then I can go ahead and
add this style right here.
So I can just add that
to my set of styles.
And then I could take
something else,
like say the roads.
And let's just simplify those,
make them a little cleaner.
So now we have a
much cleaner--
less labels and so forth,
thinner lines, if you have
that style.
And then some other things
that we could do.
We could take just the geometry
of our administrative
areas and turn all of those up,
and various other things
like that, or what have you.
There's a lot of great
examples of
Styled Maps out there.
But use this wizard.
And then when you're done with
the wizard, go ahead and hit
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] button down
at the bottom of your set
of map styles.
Here's the syntax we use
to style the maps.
And you can basically cut and
paste this into your maps API
location, along with just one
or two lines where you can
pass into your map object an
extra parameter of styles.
And you can just feed it this.
And it'll take over your base
map style with whatever you've
customized here.
So it's really easy to add
styles to your map.
And this also applies to
terrain, and you can also
create a separate map layer
where someone clicks a button
and it takes them to your styled
map, and so forth.
And there are examples of all of
that on our examples pages.
So anyway, I would recommend
checking out this wizard if
you just want to start playing
with how different styles
could look and going down the
granularity of features that
you can turn off.
Turn your parks a little
bit more green, and
so on and so forth.
So that's an overview
of the Styled Maps.
Do you have anything to add?
KATHRYN HURLEY: No.
They're very nice maps.
JOSH LIVNI: They're
beautiful, yes.
I'm not a cartographer
by trade.
Obviously.
Yes, it does make it easy
for you to play with.
Do we have anyone else on
here with questions?
KATHRYN HURLEY: Can you
replicate how they created
that one map without anything
except for the labels?
JOSH LIVNI:Yeah, absolutely.
Let's try that.
That's a good idea.
So I'm going to go ahead
and reset this.
And remove these guys.
Good-bye.
So here's our basic map again.
Let's see if I can
figure it out.
The first thing I'm
going to do--
I've never tried this--
is turn everything off.
Boring map, let's
add that style.
And then I'm going to
go to our labels and
turn everything on.
And we're done!
That was easy.
Now I might want to say, this
is pretty cool, but the
freeway labels I don't love as
much as the rest. And so I can
add this style that
we have here.
And then say, just for the
roads, let's go ahead and turn
those guys off.
And now we just have the
other labels on for the
administrative areas.
So you can take advantage of
making sure that you're
applying your labels in order,
and you can see the effect
that we have here.
If you change the order,
you're going to have a
different effect.
OK.
I think that's it.
So, let's see here.
I'm getting some notes.
Oh, let's go to our moderator
questions.
Good idea.
Excellent idea.
We have some questions.
I think that this
first question--
I'll give it a big check
mark, excellent
question, we answered.
Are you using Street View images
to find and interpret
business signs and places
to Google Maps halfway?
The answer here is we do look
at a lot of the data that
comes back from the Street
View cars, and we run all
kinds of analysis on that data,
ranging from where the
cars are and taking into account
all kinds of things
that they interact with
along the way.
I don't know for sure we're
using OCR recognition on
business signs.
It's kind of a trick problem.
You've got all these little
A-frames out on the sidewalk
and different labels that might
or might not apply to
the business itself that
might be in the window.
I'd have to ask the team.
My guess would be that
they thought of that.
But certainly, the best way
to think about adding your
business would be to add it in
Map Maker, not put a big sign
in your window and wait
for the cars to go by.
But good question.
I'm not [INAUDIBLE].
And my guess would be that's
a tricky issue that would
probably only, in the best
case scenario, apply to a
small amount of businesses.
OK.
Next question.
Why does it take as much
time to update
the Street View images?
Shall I answer that question?
Why does it take
a lot of time?
There are a lot of things
that have to occur.
First of all, we have to have
someone taking the images.
So you have to drive
a car around,
which is time consuming.
And so you can imagine, as soon
as we're done in one area
of the country, we don't just
immediately re-do that city.
There's other interesting areas
maybe we've updated.
It's kind of a similar question,
of why don't you
update your satellite imagery
and Google Earth everywhere,
over the whole world
every day?
And the answer is, we always
have to decide for the cost
that it takes to acquire the
imagery and process it, what's
the most positive affect
it can have on all
of our users worldwide.
And so with Street View,
it turns out there's
just a lot of roads.
And so the biggest slowdown is
obviously driving the cars and
getting back the imagery or
perhaps taking the boats down
the Amazon and getting
the imagery.
There's just tons of new areas
to got out, and it's
time-consuming to do that.
But then after we drive through
a place, obviously we
have to post-process all of that
data and make sure that
the quality is appropriate and
make sure that it's sort of
better imagery than we had
before, and then get it into
our systems and put it out.
But all of that time
in processing is
obviously less than--
you're going to see us back in
the same area probably because
we just have so much more
new area to cover.
Hopefully that answered
that question.
I don't think that
person's here.
KATHRYN HURLEY: I always
wondered that
same thing, too, actually.
JOSH LIVNI: Why don't
we just have cars
everywhere all the time?
KATHRYN HURLEY:Sometimes you'll
see a car driving
around, and you're like, oh,
someday maybe I'll be on
Google Maps.
I keep checking that one spot
to see myself there.
JOSH LIVNI:Moving on.
We've answered that NVC control
question previously.
And then, are you-- we
answered that one.
I think we are done.
I think we answered
all the questions.
There's no more questions.
One more question.
Did someone just
add a question?
Oh, here's a question.
I have made a wrapper to make it
simpler for people to pick
up and use the API.
Now I'm having trouble with
geocoding API requests and
dealing with multiple
instances.
Any tips or suggestions
are welcome.
So first, just let me mention
the word wrapper.
I'm not familiar with your
project offhand.
I'd point out that we do have
one clause in our terms of
service that relates to building
a wrapper library
around the Maps API itself.
And I was just reading
the terms of service.
I searched for the word,
I think, wrapper.
But read them through and make
sure that you're not
potentially violating any
of the terms in there.
And if you have a question, you
can toss us a note on the
forum for clarification
or otherwise ask here,
specifically if you have
a question about that.
Second question is trouble
with geocoding requests.
I'm not sure what trouble
is, exactly.
But I'm guessing, based-- when
you said multiple instances,
that you're using server side
geocoding, and that as more
people are using your servers
to do geocoding, you're
running out of quota.
That's just a guess, with
no additional context.
And if that's true, I'd suggest
that you certainly use
client side geocoding.
So each of the users that makes
geocoding requests, that
quote is being applied against
their IP and not against your
server instance.
So we have a blog post written
by my colleague Mano about--
or an article, rather, about
what the difference between
client side and server
side geocoding is.
So just do a search for that.
And again, I'm not familiar with
your library, but chances
are you want to be using
client side geocoding.
So I hope that answers
that question.
And looks like Davey's
got his hands up.
So more tricky questions.
We're ready.
DAVEY:Not tricky at
all, I think.
But the question anyhow.
I think it's for Kathryn,
this one.
It's regarding fusion
tables and security.
In my application recently I've
been starting to use the
document list API to access
the fusion tables and to
enable sharing of fusion
tables in my Android
application, using the document
list API, which is I
think the appropriate way to
share fusion tables from a
Java application.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yes,
that's correct.
DAVEY:I'm using [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
for that, for security.
But the thing is that I need
to provide the Google
documents scope there.
So although I'm only interested
in fusion tables,
the user basically gets to see
that my application wants to
access all his documents.
Is it possible to define a more
narrow scope through the
document list API so that we
only target fusion tables and
a user is made aware of that?
KATHRYN HURLEY: That's
a good question.
Not that I know of.
I think you just have to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] go back they
have listed in the Google
Document API, part of the
Google Documents list, that's
why it's using that scope.
It's something I can look
into and find out more
information for you.
DAVEY:Would it be possible to
log a feature request or
something like that, for that?
Because I think within the OR
framework there is like a
mechanism to define more
narrow scopes.
I think the Google Latitude API,
for example, allows you
to define various levels of
scopes and turn on what you
want to see.
So I think Interior should
also be possible with the
document list API.
KATHRYN HURLEY:Yes.
And please do open up a feature
request. That's a
great idea.
DAVEY:OK.
Then I had another question,
that's more of a Google
Latitude question.
I seem to recall, but I'm not
100% sure, that a couple of
months ago Google Latitude
worked for Google app domains,
non-Gmail domains.
And recently, I discovered that
it doesn't work anymore.
JOSH LIVNI: That's a
don't know offhand.
I'm not aware of any changes
that would have suddenly made
it not work on apps domains.
I actually have not tried it
myself on an apps domain.
And I don't know the answer
to that, either, offhand.
But if you want to toss a note
on G-plus to me asking that
question, I can find
out really quickly
and get back to you.
DAVEY: I have an issue in the
Latitude issue tracker.
On the Latitude website
it gives you--
it allows you to activate
latitudes from a Google Apps
domain, but it doesn't
really activate it.
It's kind of a bug in the
website, I think.
JOSH LIVNI: That sounds
very much like a bug.
Yeah let me look into that.
I'll take a look at--
We'll see what's going on.
DAVEY: And then, a final
question, regarding reverse
geocoding, which we talked about
a couple of minutes ago.
I'm also doing reverse geocoding
in my application,
Find Site, using
the standards--
I think it's the
Android reverse
geocoder that I'm using.
And very often I'm getting
no response at all.
I'm getting like this internal
error or something.
I don't think that it's quota
related, because sometimes,
for example, for the first time
today when I'm starting
the app, it immediately
gives me an error.
And like two minutes later, it's
able to reverse geocode
the address.
So it's very randomly that
it returns an error.
JOSH LIVNI: Do you know what
the error is, offhand?
DAVEY:I could look it up.
It's some kind of internal--
JOSH LIVNI: That also
definitely--
I mean, I can't say for sure
that it's possible that it's
quota related or something.
But it sounds like you should
file an issue there as well.
And if you can just supply the
exact error that it is, and
the call that you're making,
so you can nail down
what's going on.
DAVEY: I don't think it's
related to the actual
location, because sometimes
when I'm at a fixed point
where I know it is able to
reverse geocode that
latitude/longitude, sometimes
it works and
sometimes it doesn't.
JOSH LIVNI:And again,
I would suggest--
I know the Android guys are
having their regularly
scheduled Office Hours.
Ask them that same thing.
[MULTIPLE SPEAKERS]
their message as well.
And I think they have Office
Hours every day.
So perhaps even in an hour
or two from now.
I'm not sure what time it is.
You're in the Netherlands
I think--
DAVEY: Belgium.
JOSH LIVNI: --vaguely similar
area of time zones So I think
they're still having them later
on today, our time.
But otherwise, they have a list
of scheduled hours for
all of their Office Hours, and
you can ask them that.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Can I just
ask one question?
It might be a silly question,
but the phone is connected to
the internet when you're
making your requests?
DAVEY:Yeah, definitely.
Using wi-fi 3G.
I don't know.
It's a very random thing.
It's a very simple
API call to make.
You can't do any by client
sites errors with that.
It's just a simple call, reverse
geocode a certain
location point.
And like I said, sometimes
it works.
JOSH LIVNI:Interesting.
If it's only occasionally
failing, but usually working
well-- first of all, definitely
let us try to
figure out what's going
wrong here.
And as a work around, you could
potentially fall back to
using a web service on fail.
So have the service side call
in case of failing.
But yeah, it sounds like if
you're making a reverse
geocode to the exact same place
and it doesn't work, it
doesn't work, and then it works,
something's amiss.
It could be--
it's not just a daily quota,
it's also a quota of if you
ask bunch of times in a burst,
that will also get you a
denied message.
So it's hard to say without
seeing what call you're making
and what the error is.
DAVEY: I have an issue for it.
I'll make sure I have the
exact error message.
JOSH LIVNI:OK.
You're always finding out
good edge cases for us.
DAVEY: I would make a great
tester probably.
JOSH LIVNI:OK.
Any other questions?
OK.
KATHRYN HURLEY: If anybody's
on YouTube, a
reminder on how to join.
JOSH LIVNI:Yes.
If you're on YouTube, you
should-- your time is running
low here, but you can try to
make a run for the G-plus
stream of Mano Marks
or myself.
And wherever you saw this post.
And you can ping Mano
and ask him to add you to a
circle, which will then allow
you to join the Hangout live
and ask questions.
OK.
Well I think we're going
to wrap it up.
Did you have anything else
you wanted to cover?
KATHRYN HURLEY:Nothing.
JOSH LIVNI: The new Styled
Maps, please.
That was the main takeaway I
wanted to give you guys.
Oh, yes.
One more question.
We're ready for it.
Ask away.
Captive audience.
MALE SPEAKER:OK.
So the last one.
So I was trolling stack overflow
for Google Maps API
questions, trying to get some
that I could answer.
And there's one which is a
reference to a tutorial done
by Google, where you use the
static map API to put a static
image in, and then when the map
fully loads, you switch
the static image with the live
content using the API.
But that particular
tutorial/example uses the
version 2 API.
So the version 2 JavaScript Maps
API, not the version 2
static maps API.
And so the personal stack
overflow was asking
essentially Google, but I
think someone else may
volunteer, to update
the API part of the
tutorial for version 3.
JOSH LIVNI:Yes.
We should probably--
MALE SPEAKER:Fundamental
question,
is that a good practice?
JOSH LIVNI: It is
a good practice.
In fact, the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
API automatically does this
under certain circumstances.
For example, on a mobile
device or if there's a
relatively low bandwith
connection, we will, by
default, load a static map and
then bring in the full
JavaScript API when it's
finished loading.
So if you're looking on a mobile
phone, that's very
likely what's occurring anyway
by default in a webpage where
you're just loading
the Maps v3.
So you don't need to go to any
extra effort at all yourself.
But on a desktop website,
we might not do that.
And if for some reason you did
want to do it-- or another
common use case is you just have
a bunch of pages on your
website and you think it's
unlikely someone might click
on the map for any
interactivity.
You see the little
thumbnail there.
There's no need for you to load
up the entire JavaScript
API each time.
You could just load the static
map, and then when someone
clicks on it or something like
that, bring in the full
interactivity.
So there are going to be some
cases for doing that.
And it's not a bad idea for us
to update the example to show
that feature.
But if you're just concerned
about having a little speedier
instant access to someone
looking at a map on a mobile
device, and that's the reason
you're interested, note that
the v3 automatically
does that for you.
Also, if you are going to take
any of these approaches, pay
attention to the quota of maps
that you're using, static and
regular JavaScript
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Did that answer your question?
MALE SPEAKER: That did, sorry.
You muted--
But yes, that answered
the question.
Thank you very much.
JOSH LIVNI:Davey had one
more question, I think.
DAVEY:Sorry.
JOSH LIVNI: No, don't be.
It's great.
We want to be here to
answer questions.
DAVEY:What do you guys think of
the performance of Google
Maps when run through a web
view on a mobile device?
Because usually what you do is,
in like an Android or an
IOS, you have like these
dedicated map components that
you can use, native components,
that are very
responsive.
They support pinch and
zoom very well,
all these fancy gestures.
JOSH LIVNI: Obviously, it's
going to be faster to run the
compiled code off the native
application than it is to load
the web view.
It's often just inherently
faster to do that than to have
an embedded browser load up
the JavaScript and then
compile them from
that on the fly.
That's always going
to be true.
That said, there are still a
bunch of additional features
that we have in the JavaScript
Maps API that aren't in the
native one.
So it's just a choice to use as
developer, if that feature
meets your needs for whatever
hardware you're running on,
which one to use.
But I think it is
pretty speedy.
It's a pretty speedy load.
Like we mentioned in the last
question, you get a map very,
very quickly.
Is it a few hundred milliseconds
here or there
potentially before everything
occurs?
I'm not sure exactly
what the tests are.
It's always going to be a little
faster no matter what
to run things on the
native outlet.
DAVEY: Yes, especially when you
load up lots of markers on
the map and you try to navigate
through the map
really quickly.
That's something that you can
do in a really fancy way on
the native component, like you
put a bunch of markers-- like
I had, in my application I put a
bunch of markers on the map.
I have display button.
My replay, all of my locations
on the map component, which is
really fluid in the
native components.
Whereas if I load it up on the
standard browser in a web
view, it's actually--
it's not a tad slower, but it's
a lot slower, if you know
what I mean.
And I was wondering,
is there like--
do you guys see that
progressing, in the sense that
with Chrome coming to Android
might that give better
performance, or do you see stuff
like WebGL also coming
to mobile devices in
the near future?
JOSH LIVNI:Well, slowly WebGL
is being made available on
more and more phones.
And the hardware phones, of
course, is getting better.
And at the same time, we're
trying really hard to optimize
all the features on Maps v3 to
be as snappy as possible on
the whole spectrum of
devices out there.
So if you're seeing a regression
in terms of
something that used to be
faster, let's say a hundred or
a thousand markers, potentially
pushing the limits
of some phones, then
let us know.
Because it should certainly
not be getting slower, it
should be getting faster.
And we are trying to take
advantage if the browser can
support something like Canvas
or different techniques that
we can use to make hte markers
snappy, then we'll use those
techniques.
So you should be able to get
increasingly more and
increasingly faster markers
over Web View.
And if you're seeing the
opposite of that, definitely
give us a heads up.
DAVEY:I'm not seeing the
opposite, it's just comparing
it with the native component,
like the speed gap is
substantial, I mean.
JOSH LIVNI:OK.
Well, that's good feedback.
I'm not going to chat
again with the team.
I know they're aware of a lot of
different phones out there
and trying to make things
as snappy as possible.
Yes, and again, there's always
going to be some optimal
things that you can do in native
application, no matter
what you want to do, compared
to running it
through a Web View.
But that said, we should
certainly try to make sure
that those cases where there
are 500-plus markers to
display, it's feasible to do
that in some way on Web View.
--without any kind
of noticeable
slowdown, if possible.
DAVEY:Because my company is
trying to move away from the
entire native development
thing.
They want to do cross platform,
HTML5 developments.
Like write once and run on any
device, which I don't really
think is technically possible
all the time.
But we're trying to see what the
capabilities are of using
the JavaScript in the JavaScript
Maps API in a Web
View, and see what the
performance is.
JOSH LIVNI:Absolutely.
And if you do notice something
where you think--
I have no idea of the number
of markers you're doing,
exactly what kind of effects
you're doing to them and so
forth, that seems like it's
not what you would expect,
file a feature request or a bug
and say, this doesn't seem
quite right.
Because now Street View should
be pretty snappy on mobile
devices, certainly for many
hundreds of markers.
It should not be a noticeable
slow down
on any modern device.
DAVEY:OK.
JOSH LIVNI:I think we're going
to finish it up here.
So thanks a lot, guys, for
joining us and for all the
good questions.
We'll be back, I think,
next week.
I'm not sure of the
exact date.
But you can check our SG-plus
streams. And we will look
forward to seeing whoever wants
to join us next week.
So thanks again for coming by.